the wind turbines you see behind me are
part of one of the largest wind farms in
europe they're also the reason why there
aren't any reindeer roaming the area of
fusion anymore reindeer used to roam
this vast area of mid-norway only a few
years back
now the animals are long gone
instead
one of europe's biggest wind power
plants is dominating the area of fusion
but the wind powered development has
made it almost impossible for the
indigenous sami people to hurt reindeer
in an unexpected ruling late last year
norway's supreme court stated that the
wind turbines was built on permits that
are no longer valid the reason is that
the permits breaches the sami people's
right to exercise its culture
[Music]
[Music]
and several ngos now demand that the
wind plant consisting of
151 wind turbines
is being dismantled so the animals can
return
so far
nothing has happened
the turbines are still in operation and
norway's government hasn't offered a
solution yet on one hand the government
has said that it will be a world leader
when it comes to indigenous people's
rights on the other hand the nation
needs renewable energy and the
government could also be held
responsible for the wind company's loss
if the turbines are to be torn down
norway's new government has described
this as one of the most difficult cases
in several years prime minister yunus
garciarde said in february that he
understand the sami's frustration
but that there is nothing in the ruling
that implies that the turbines has to be
dismantled as the government is looking
for solutions nobody knows if the
reindeer will be able to return to the
area where they've been winter grazing
for hundreds of years